The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So it's my pleasure
to introduce Professor Saman
Amarasignhe as our
guest lecturer today.
So Saman Amarasignhe
is a professor
in the EECS Department at MIT.
And he's also the
associate department head.
He's an expert in compilers,
domain specific languages,
and autotuning.
In fact, he was the designer
of the OpenTuner framework
that you've been using for
your homework assignments.
So today Saman is
going to tell us
about some of his recent work
on domain specific languages
and also on autotuning.
So let's give Saman Amarasignhe
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE: Thank you.
OK, so I used to teach this
class for many, many years.
Unfortunately, now I am
administrator, so I don't--
Julian and Charles get to have
the fun teaching the class.
So hopefully you
guys enjoyed your--
now you're starting-- you
are done project one, two,
and three and going
into project four?
Yeah, project four
is really fun and--
[LAUGHTER]
It will look big and
daunting, but at the end,
you'll enjoy it, and especially
all the amount of time people
spend working on it.
So I think I'm making you
scared here, more than anything.
OK, so let's get
into the talk today.
So I will talk to you about
domain specific languages
and a little bit
about autotuning,
how it leads to autotuning.
So why is domain
specific languages?
So we are all used to
general purpose languages
that we use all day.
And those languages
are set up to capture
a very large sort
of what people might
want to do in programming.
However, a lot of
times there are
specific areas, specific
domains, either some area in--
that you want to implement, or
the certain patterns you want
to implement code that has a
lot of interesting properties
that in a general
purpose language
it's very hard to describe.
And a lot of times it's
basically very hard,
especially from compiler point
of view, to take advantage.
Because it has to
work for everybody.
So domain specific
languages basically
has this lot of
integrated benefits.
Because if you know that you
are-- what you're building
has a certain shape,
certain set of properties,
if the language captured this,
and if you're building on that,
it could be much
easier to build.
It should have a lot of clarity.
It's very easy to maintain
that kind of thing.
It's very easy to test.
And also, the other thing is,
it's very easy to understand.
Because the domain is
very clearly described.
If-- you can build a
library, but somebody
can go and do weird
things in library.
If it is built into the
language, it's set in stone.
You can't go and
say, oh, yeah, I'm
going to change something here.
Let me do some weird thing here.
It's built into the language.
So it stays there.
It makes it much easier for
programmers [INAUDIBLE]..
But from my point of view,
the domain specific language
I really like are
the languages where
I know I can take advantage of
knowledge of the domain experts
to get really good performance.
So a lot of times,
domain experts
say, ah ha, in this
domain, I can do--
OK, there's some linear algebra,
but I know this kind of algebra
that I can do to
simplify the expression.
That algebra might only
work on that domain.
It's very hard to put some
complex algebra into C++ or C.
But in that domain, I can
say, ha, I can call it up.
So you can write any expression
that I can simplify it.
And also, there are a lot
of idioms in each domain.
So some domain
might say, OK, look,
I am going to represent a graph
that I'm going to talk about.
In the normal C++, you
create a bunch of classes.
You do these very
complicated things.
The idiom is hidden in there.
First of all, C++ doesn't know
that I had to look for graphs.
But even if you had
look for graphs,
you can try graphs in
hundreds of millions of ways.
But if it is a first class
supporting the language,
I don't have to work
heroically to extract that.
It's there.
I can easily see that.
So most of my compiler can be
doing useful things in there.
And most of the
time, the other thing
is, if you build a domain
specific language right,
you can leave the complex,
the lower level decision,
to the compiler.
And if you-- C++, you might
be tempted to say, eh,
I know some optimization.
Let me do something here.
Oh, let me do some of
the optimizations here.
So I have been working on
optimization all my life.
And a lot of times, when you
write a compile optimization
part, you spend half of or more
than half of your time undoing
the crazy optimization
the programmer did,
like you guys are learning.
So this-- you think
you know better.
You go do something.
And that might work well
then, but believe me,
that code survives
20 years later.
And 20 years later, that looks
like a really stupid thing
to do.
And then you look at
it and say, OK, now I
had to undo everything
in the compiler,
do the right thing in
the current architecture.
And because of that, if you
capture the right level,
I will let the compiler
do the work in here.
And then as the
architectures keep maturing,
as the problems keep changing,
I don't have to worry.
I don't have to undo
these parts in here.
So again, I'm coming to the
performance engineering class
and telling you guys, leave the
performance to the compiler.
But that's the nice thing,
that if the compiler
can do the most of your
work, much nicer job.
So don't doubt the compiler.
So I'm going to talk
about three parts in here.
One is three different
programming languages
in here, domain specific
languages, GraphIt, Halide,
and then OpenTuner, which
is not just the language,
but the framework in here.
And between GraphIt and Halide,
you will see some patterns.
And then we'll see whether
you found the pattern
that we are working on in here.
So GraphIt, this is a product
that I worked with Julian.
So if you have any questions
of GraphIt after today,
you can definitely
go ask Julian.
He knows probably more
about graphs and GraphIt--
more about graphs than probably
anybody on this planet.
So he's a good resource
to talk about graphs.
So talking about graphs,
graphs everywhere.
So if you go to something like
Google and do some search,
Google has represented
the entire knowledge
on the internet as a big graph.
They have done a huge amount
of graph processing behind you.
That is how-- what guides
your search in there.
Or if you go, again, maps,
or something like Uber,
it will find your directions.
The entire road
network is a graph.
And it's trying to find
things like shortest path
in this graph to
give you the map.
And if you go to a
recommendation engine to get
a recommendation for a movie, if
you get a really cool movie you
like, that's because there's
a huge graph between everybody
who's-- which movie
they've watched,
and their likings
to those movies.
And they are looking and
comparing you to them
and recommending that.
That's all can be viewed
as graphs in here.
And even if you go to an ATM
and try to do a transaction,
there's a very fast
graph analysis back
to say is this a fraudulent
transaction or not?
So most of the transactions
people have done,
all the connectivities
in the back in there,
before the time that actually
the money pops out of your ATM
machine, it has done a bunch of
graph processes to understand,
OK, this seems like
a good transaction.
So I will actually
give you the money.
Sometimes you say-- you
get this other message that
mean the graph
processing decided
there might be some weird
thing going on there.
So a lot of these things
that some of them,
like maps and graphs has--
maps and these transactions
have very fine latency thing
in there.
You have to get this
thing done right.
You have to get good directions.
Especially if you
take a wrong turn,
you need to get the
next set of directions
done very fast before you go hit
some Boston bad weird traffic.
So these things
have to work fast.
And other things, like
recommendations and Google
Search, is huge graph.
They build the entire web,
then all the recommendations
have to do a huge
amount of processing.
So performance matters a
lot in these applications.
So let me dive down a
little bit deeper into show
what graphs means, what
graph processing means.
So one of the very well
known graph algorithms
is called PageRank.
Anybody knows [INAUDIBLE] page?
How many have heard of PageRank?
OK, what does page
stand in page rank?
AUDIENCE: Larry Page.
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE: Larry Page.
So the first
algorithm Google did--
I don't think this is anywhere
near Google at this point--
was this algorithm, PageRank.
So it ranked these pages.
But it was developed
by Larry Page.
So it depends on either page--
it's web pages or Larry Page.
We don't know.
But people think it's
Larry Page is PageRank.
So you have a graph in here.
So this graph
algorithm, what it does
it is [INAUDIBLE]
to some iterations,
either it's max_iter on to
some convergence in here.
So what it first do is
it will go around, look
at all its neighbors,
and calculate,
basically rank a new rank
out of all my neighbors.
So that means what is--
how good are my neighbors?
What's their rank?
And what's their
contribution to me?
So it means being
known to a good person
and having a connection
to a very well known--
in this case, a super web
page-- means I am highly ranked.
So I am more
influential, because I'm
closer to something in there.
So what it does is,
basically, it will go--
each node calculates some
value, and propagate to all
the neighbors, and aggregating.
So entire graph
participating in that.
And then, what
happens is each node
will go about calculating
its new rank in there.
From looking at old rank,
it get modified a little bit
towards a new rank.
And then they swap old
ranks and new ranks.
So this is the two computations
that you iterate over that.
And you have to do for
the entire graph in here.
So, of course, you can run this.
This will run very, very
slowly if you run this.
So if you want to
get performance,
you write this piece of code.
So this piece of code,
basically, is huge.
And it runs 23 times
faster than what's
in the previous graph in
here on a 12 core machine.
It basically had
multi-threaded so we'd
get parallel performance.
It is load balanced
because, as you know,
graphs are very unbalanced.
So you get load balance.
If you have non-uniform
memory access machines, things
like multiple socket machines,
it will take advantage of that.
It advantage of caches--
a lot of things happening
in this piece of code.
But, of course, you know
this is hard to write
this piece of code.
But also, worse, you
might not know what to do,
what the right optimizing--
you might only iterate.
You might try many things.
And this is very hard.
Every time you change
something, if you say,
ah, I want to do something
a little bit different,
that I had to write a very
complicated piece of code,
get it all right, get everything
working before I test in here.
So this is why we can
use a DSL for this one.
So let me go a little bit,
talk about graph algorithms
and say this seems like
a new set of [INAUDIBLE]..
So what do people
do with graphs?
So when they say
graph algorithms,
I'm going to go a
little bit deep down
to show you what type of
things represent these graphs.
There's one class
of graph algorithms
that are called
topology-driven algorithms.
That means the entire
graph participates
in the computation.
For example, Google Search--
before you do Google
Search, it will
do the entire basic collection
of all the web links.
It will build this
huge graph and do
huge amount of processing
to basically able
to do the search in here.
Recommendation engine-- so
every, probably few weeks,
or whatever it is, it
will collect everybody's
recommendations,
have this huge data,
and you're going to process
that and do this recommendation
engine.
So this is applied
for the entire graphs,
and sometimes billions
or trillions of nodes
have to go into
this computation.
Another set of algorithms is
called data-driven algorithms.
So what that means is you
start with certain nodes.
And then you keep going to its
neighbors and its neighbors
processing data in
here as we do that.
And the kind of algorithms
that fit in this category
are things like
if you have a map,
if I had to find the shortest
path, that means I have,
probably two paths.
I don't have to get in from
direction from here to Boston.
I don't have to go through
New York nodes in New York.
I just have to go through my
neighbors connected to me.
So I am basically
operating on a certain area
with some connections
and processing that.
So these are
data-driven algorithms.
So I might have a huge graph.
But my computation
might only work
on a small region or a
small part of the graph
in these algorithms.
So when you traversing
through a graph doing that,
there are multiple ways
of doing graph traversals.
And this is why
optimization is hard.
Because there are many
different ways of doing things.
And each has different set
of outcomes you can get.
So I see a lot of
graph algorithms.
I need to get something
from my neighbors.
One way to get something
my neighbors is I
can calculate what the
neighbor-- all my neighbors
might want and give it
to all the neighbors.
Or I can go change all the
neighbors to update my value.
So why do you think--
OK, you have done some
programming in here.
What do you think about this?
Is this a good way?
So if I want to
update everybody,
I will calculate what
I will do, and I'll
go change everybody,
all my neighbors.
AUDIENCE: This is not as
parallel as it could be.
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE: Not as
I think you are
getting to a point.
But why is not that parallel?
AUDIENCE: Well, if you're
doing the same thing
with the neighbors, you might
as well just tell your neighbors
to do the work for you.
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE: Yeah, but--
that's a very good point.
So if you are doing a
data-driven, if I'm doing,
that's not good.
But if everybody is doing
that to their neighbor,
so then I have parallelism.
So everybody might say, you
are updated your neighbor.
You are updating
your-- everybody
is updating their neighbors.
So now there's another
problem showing up.
What's the problem
if everybody tried
to update their neighbors?
Back there.
AUDIENCE: There's a
determinancy race.
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE:
There's a race in there.
Because everybody's
going right in there.
So if you want to get
this actually right,
you have a bunch of issues here.
You want to basically
do atomic updates.
Because you need
to lock that thing.
So it has get atomically
updated in here.
And this is nice.
But I don't have to
traverse anything.
Because everybody
I need to update,
I actually go and update it.
That's nice way to
do that, especially
if it is not a global thing.
So if I'm propagating, I
will update my neighbors.
And I can propagate that down.
Another way to do
that is pull schedule.
That means if I--
everybody look at-- ask their
neighbors, OK, do you have--
what you have to--
give it to me.
And I collect everything
from my neighbors.
And I update myself.
So is there a race
condition now?
How many people say
there is a race?
How many people think
there's no race?
So what happens is I'm reading
from all the neighbors.
Everybody is reading
from the neighbors.
But I am only updating myself.
So because of that, I'm the
only one who's writing me.
So I don't have a race.
So it is really nice
you don't have a race.
But I might-- if I'm doing a
data-driven transformation,
I might not know that
I need to get updated.
Because the update
comes from that person.
And that means I
might be asking you,
do you have anything to send?
And you might say no.
So in that sense,
I might basically
doing a lot of extra
computation than necessary.
Because I might not know that
I have data I need to get.
But I had to ask you
whether I should do this.
But I don't have any, basically,
need to do any synchronization.
Another interesting thing
is I can take this graph,
and I can basically
partition the graph.
And once I partition
the graph, I
can basically say, OK,
this core get this graph.
This core get this graph.
Or this processor
node get this graph.
What's the advantage of
partitioning a graph?
Why do I want to partition
a graph-- large graph
into small pieces?
Of course, you had to
do a good partition.
You can't do
arbitrary partition.
So what happens if I
do a good partitioning?
I don't tell the word, because
then the answer comes out
in there.
OK, let me see if anybody
else, you have answered--
anybody else want to answer?
Come on.
You have to-- [INAUDIBLE].
What happened if I take apart,
and find two different groups,
and separate them, and give
this one to one and this one
to another?
What do I get?
AUDIENCE: You get
some parallelism.
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE: I
get parallelism, also.
But other thing, if I have a
lot of connected things going
to-- these connected things
going to that person,
what else can I get?
Locality-- have you heard?
Did you do locality
in the class?
So that means-- the
partition means my--
the thing I'm working, I am
only working on a small amount.
And that might, if I'm
lucky, fit in my cache.
And that would be very
nice then everybody's has
to go to every node in here.
So if I partition
this properly, I
will get good locality in here.
It's actually written
there, whoops.
So my answer was in there,
so improved locality.
But, of course, now I might have
a little bit extra overhead.
Because I know I might have
to replicate some nodes,
stuff like that.
Because it's in both sides.
So another interesting
in properties of graphs
is when you look at data
structures until now,
things like arrays,
the size matters.
These represent what
array fits in the cache,
and stuff like that.
Graphs, there are
some other properties
of the graphs in here.
So if you go to
social networks--
social network is a graph--
what's the interesting
property in social networks
you have observed?
AUDIENCE: Connectedness.
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE:
Connectedness--
there are people
like me that probably
have 20 friends in
there and has a very
little number of connections.
And then there are
celebrities who have millions
of connections in here.
So the interesting thing is,
if you look at a social network
graph, you have this
relationship called power law
relationship.
That means-- there's
exponential code.
There are some people here,
like very well-known celebrities
that might have millions and
millions of users in here--
connections in
neighbors, or likes,
or whatever it is in that node.
And there are people
like me sitting here
that has very little
people connected
to the rest of the world.
So this is normally-- people
have observed these big social
network type graphs--
you have this kind of
exponential relationship
in here.
So the web has
exponential relationship.
A social network has this
kind of relationship in there.
So those things you have to
do very interesting things
when you process these graphs.
Because there are certain
connections that matter,
certain nodes that
matter a lot, or has
a big impact than other nodes.
Then there are other
graphs that have
a bounded-degree distribution.
If you have a road network,
the maximum connection,
probably you might
have an intersection
that has six roads coming
to together in there.
You don't have a million roads
connecting into one place
anywhere in there.
So that doesn't happen.
So this is a lot more
flatter, a lot more
bounded-degree distribution
graphs in here.
They have lots of
excellent locality in here
because, of course, all
the roads in Cambridge
might be connected.
But roads in Cambridge
can be separated
from roads in New York City.
So there they are separated.
They are locality--
nice locality
in these kind of graphs.
So even the-- if
you say the graph be
the same size, the
shape of the graph
matters in computation,
a lot of times.
So what happens is
now when you want
to operate on these
graphs, you have
to look at three
interesting properties.
One property is, OK,
how much parallelism
my algorithm, what I'm
trying to do to this graph
is going to get?
It's like a
Goldilocks type thing.
You don't want too
much parallelism.
If you say, I have
algorithm that huge amount
of parallelism, if I can't take
advantage, it's not useful.
So you need to get a
parallelism good enough
that I can actually use it.
Then I really like
to have locality.
Because if I have a locality,
my caches will work.
Everything will be nearby.
I can get-- runs things fast.
If I, every time, I have to
get something from main memory,
it can be very, very slow.
So I want to get locality.
But the interesting
thing about graphs
is to get localities
and get some of these,
you might have to
do some extra work.
So if you saw that
graph got divided
into two different graphs, I
had to add extra nodes in here.
I might write some
extra data structures,
so do some extra computation.
So I might have to do
some extra work in here.
So in certain things, I might
not be that work efficient.
So I might get really good
parallelism and locality,
but I am doing too much work.
So, for example, if I want to--
assume I want to find
one node's neighbor,
very way to get
good parallelism,
everybody finds their neighbor.
OK, but that's not efficient.
I mean, most of the
computation's not useful.
So there, you can do
things that you are doing
extra work than necessary.
Then that can get much
faster other things.
But you have to be
careful on doing that.
So you have this
balance in there.
So certain algorithms will fit
in different places in here
in this tradeoff space.
So push algorithm
will fit in here.
So, for example, if
you go to something
like a pull algorithm,
what you might find
is you are doing
less work efficient.
Because you might do a
little bit more work.
But it might be better in
locality and parallelism,
because you don't have
to do locks in here.
And then you do something
like partitioning.
It gets really good
locality in partitioning.
But you are doing extra work.
And also, because
in your partition,
you might limit your
parallelism in here.
So you might less
parallelism, but you
get really good locality.
So all this is basically
large tradeoff space in here.
And then when you keep
adding more and more things
you can do, it fits into
this big tradeoff space.
So how do you decide what to go
in the tradeoff space is a very
important thing-- decision.
So it depends on the graphs.
If you have power law graphs,
you might want to do something.
If you have a more
limited distributed graph,
you want to do something else.
And the power law
graphs, sometimes
you might do something different
for the high connected edges
versus others.
You might not even
differentiate between that.
It depends on the algorithm.
So if you are doing--
visiting all the nodes, whereas
as a data-driven algorithm,
you might do
something different.
It also depends on the
hardware you're running.
So, for example, if you
are doing a Google search,
basically indexing,
you're running
an algorithm that has to operate
on the entire graph in here.
And the graph is a
power law graph in that.
And you're running on a cluster.
So the right thing
might be something
like a pull schedule with some
partitioning and something
like a vertex
parallel, or some kind
of a parallelism scheme
in here might give you
the best performance.
But in the other
side of the Google,
if you're trying to do
a map, and if you're
trying to give you
directions, you
have a very different
type of a graph.
You are doing a data-driven
algorithm in that graph.
And you might be running
on a single machine.
Because you need
to give direction
fast for each individual time.
You might have a very
different type of algorithm
you want to run
this graph, the push
algorithm in vertex
parallel, perhaps,
some combination in there.
And, of course, if you get a
bad algorithm or bad set of--
way of doing it,
you can be very bad.
You can get hundreds of
thousands times slower
than the best you can achieve.
So it matters to
find the right thing,
right way of doing things.
So this is where
GraphIt came in.
GraphIt is a domain specific
language, basically,
we developed.
And one thing GraphIt did
was we said, OK, look,
the algorithm is
mostly constant.
But how you process
the-- how you go about it
is very different.
So we want to
separate these things.
So the first thing
we did was come up
with the algorithm, which is
what do you want to compute?
It's very high level.
It don't tell you how we are
computing that-- saying this
is my algorithm.
I aim to process these nodes.
And this is the computation
I want to do in there.
And you separate it with
an optimizational schedule
how to compute.
So we'd say, OK, to
do this algorithm,
you had to do a push schedule,
do this type of parallelism--
each separately.
And the nice thing is that
is now, if the graph changed
or if the matching
changed, I can give you
a different schedule in here.
So let me show
you some examples.
First, look at the
algorithm in here.
So we show three different
types of things you want to do.
So you want to do the
entire graph in here,
have the data-driven.
Or I might want to just operate
on the vertices in here.
So this one we have--
the language provides a very
simple way of doing that.
Language has this
function saying,
if there are edges, all the
edges of the graph, apply--
you can give a function.
The function takes the,
basically, nodes and the edges,
basically-- it to
basically carry out
this computation, a very
simple way of doing that.
So this is the representation.
So the nice thing, the
simplicity of programming now.
If I write it in C, it will look
like a big blob of ugly code.
In the domain specific language,
all you have to write is this--
make life very simple.
Or if you're a
data-driven language,
I have to say, OK, I start
with this set of vertices
to compute in here.
And here are the vertices
I am going to in here,
the vertex sent here.
And then I do some filtering.
Because I might not
go visit everybody.
There are some filtering
of what you can do.
And then once you figure
out exactly the things
you are computing,
here's a function
to go and apply to that.
So I can give you some very
nice way of basically subsetting
my graph with
certain properties,
select those things, and
now go compute there.
And if you're only
doing vertices,
say, OK, for each
vertices, again, I
can filter, saying this
subset or something go
to that computation.
So language-wise,
it's very simple.
This is what all you had to do.
Now if you look at
PageRank, PageRank
has two interesting
update functions.
What is-- one is
updating, going--
looking at edges.
So what it says is new rank,
I get the destination edge.
And it gets updated using
all the source edges in here.
This is the update function,
very simple update function.
And then once you do that
for each, basically, vertex,
I go do internal update.
I give these two functions and
put them together into driver.
And the driver says run this
function, run this function,
and I'm done.
OK, so I can write this
code at higher level, much
simpler, much nicer,
much more elegant way.
It's much easier to understand.
It's easier than even the
simple C++ code to understand
what's going on if you
write it in this way.
So this is the first advantage
of a domain specific language.
I can do this.
Then the next thing
you can do is now
I can come up with the schedule.
So schedules should
be easy to use.
And it should be
powerful enough I
should be able to get
the best speed possible.
Because I can tell you
all the crazy things
I can do to the code.
So here's my program
here for PageRank.
And so what I can do
is, for this algorithm,
I can provide this
schedule in here.
And this schedule basically
says, OK, look at this guy, s1.
I marked it in there.
For s1, I want to do
SparsePush type computation.
This is how I want
to process this one.
And then, by looking at that,
I can generate a pseudo code
that looks like this
that basically first goes
through a source node,
because I'm doing push
from source to destination.
And then I'm going through
all the destination
nodes of that source.
And I'm going to actually
go and update them.
So I can do this very
simple updating here.
But this might not get
you that performance.
I say, ah ha, I want to
do this in parallelism.
I want to run this parallel.
And then when I do that, it
will automatically generate,
say ah ha, now, I will
make this two parallel.
And now I can't
do simple updates.
I have to atomic add.
So here's my atomic
add operation--
so the graph in here.
Then you might think, and say,
mm, do I want to do the push?
Can I do a pull?
So if I do a pull chain, it
will basically switch the--
in here.
Now I am going from
destination to source.
I changed order in there.
And now I don't have to
do that atomic update.
Because I am pulling everything
to my node and updating here.
And then, of course, if
you want to do some kind
of partitioning, I can
also say partitioning,
it's-- now we created
a sub-graph in here.
And for the sub-graph, I
am doing this partitioning.
So I can keep changing
all these things.
Look, I didn't touch this.
My algorithm still stays same.
I'm changing my scheduling.
I can play with this schedule.
Nice thing about
that is now if you
keep playing with
the schedule, here's
the kind of performance I get.
The first guy was sequential,
pretty bad performance.
The next guy, I just
parallelized in here.
I got some performance in here.
But it had all the
synchronization.
So I changed the
order of execution.
And I got an even
better performance.
And now I partitioned, got
[INAUDIBLE] performance.
So this is the
order of doing that.
But, of course, you can play
with many, many different
combinations.
And what GraphIt
has is huge number
of different combinations
you can play with.
So there are a lot of
different optimizations.
You can do direction
optimizations,
push, pull, doing a
sparse, dense, different
parallelization, cache,
NUMA optimization, and also
data layout, things like
structures of arrays,
array of structure layout,
additional data structures that
simplify computation.
All these things I
can specify in here.
And then you can play with it.
It's not clear which one wins.
It depends on the algorithm,
depending on the graph shape,
graph size, depending
on the machine you run.
So most of the time, if you
are a performance engineer,
you'll be trying
different things,
and looking at the
performance, and say, this
doesn't get good cache behavior.
OK, let me try different things.
So you want to iterate.
And these iterations,
you want to do fast.
And this will do that.
So let me tell you a
little bit of results.
This is a--
I have to explain.
This a little bit of
a complicated graph.
So what we looked at
was shown against bunch
of different benchmarks, a
bunch of different frameworks
that do graphs.
So what they says is here is
a program, PageRank, ran all
on a graph like
general graph in here.
One means it ran the fastest.
This ran about 8% slower.
This ran 50% slower.
This ran 3x slower, and
8x lower for that graph.
The interesting thing is as
you add more different graphs,
the performance changes.
So, in fact, even
though we ran fastest
for this road graph, which are
a very different type of graph,
this framework ran the--
provided-- got the
fastest result.
Because the graph is different.
So it might be doing
something that's better.
The interesting
thing is since we
had-- because most
of other frameworks
will have a couple of
built in things they try.
They don't do, give
you all this ability
to try all this optimizing.
They say, ah ha, I know this.
This is really good.
I will do that.
It works for certain
things, not for everybody.
And so if you look at the entire
different breadth-first search,
connected components, shortest
path algorithms, what you find
is some frameworks
are good sometimes.
They might be really
bad in other times,
to either some algorithms,
some type of data,
they can be really bad.
So this algorithm was really
kind of good at this data set,
but really bad in this
data, and really kind
of not good in this algorithm.
We are most of the
time good all the time.
The reason is we don't
make a few decisions.
In GraphIt, what it will do is
it will give you this ability
to try different things.
And depending on the graph,
depending on the algorithm,
some optimizations might
work better than the other.
This is exactly what you guys
have been doing in the class.
You are trying different
optimizations by hand.
The difference is every time
you thought about optimizing,
you had to go change the entire
program to make that work.
Here you just change the
scheduling language one way,
recompile, run, measure,
and you can do this fast.
Any questions so far
before I switch gears?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE: OK.
So I'm going to switch
to another domain
specific language.
You will find a lot of
simulated, lot of parallelism
in here.
This was intentional.
I could have talked on
many different domain
specific languages.
But I took another
one that you-- almost
has kind of a mirror
similarities of what's
going on.
And you will see a pattern
in here, hopefully.
And after this, I will ask
you what the patterns are.
This language is Halide.
It was originally developed
for image processing.
And its focus is-- the graphs
focus on this past graph data
structures.
Halide's focused
on-- because images
are dense, regular structures.
You do regular
computation on the images.
And you process this thing.
And you have a very
complex pipeline.
Like, for example,
camera pipeline
do many very complex
algorithms to the image
before you get from the
bits coming out of your CCD
to the beautiful picture
you see in Facebook.
And the primary
goal of Halide was
you want to match and exceed
the hand-optimized performance,
basically.
This was the property
we want to do.
And we want to reduce the
rote amount of programming
that normally a
performance engineer has
to do to achieve this thing.
And we want to also increase
the portability, the ability
to take that program
from different machines
to different.
So let me give you an example.
Here is a three by
three blur example.
So what this does is this
[INAUDIBLE] two loops go
in the x direction and do a
blur in x direction, get the--
average the three values
next to each other.
And then it will go--
the result of that, do it in
y direction, and average that.
OK, very simple filter that
you might want to do for image,
you can run this.
This is valid C code.
But if you want to
get performance,
you want to generate this guy.
This thing, on the other
hand, ran about 11 times
faster than this one.
This has done tile.
It has fused multiple loops.
It has vectorized.
It has multi-threaded.
It had to do some
redundant computation
I'll get to a little bit later.
And it basically gives a near
roof-line optimum performance.
That means it's using the
machine resources to this max.
Because this has a bunch of
floating point operations.
So it's basically
floating point unit is
running at the max performance.
So there's nothing much else
you could do to this one.
But you write this thing.
And this is not that easy.
So this project started some
time ago with one of my--
the person who did
it-- going to Adobe.
He went to Adobe.
And they had this thing
called a local laplacian
filter in Camera
Raw, and Lightroom,
and Photoshop projects in here.
The reference implementation
was about 300 lines of code.
But the implementation
that they used
was about 1,500 lines of code.
It took three months of
one of their best engineers
to get to that performance.
But it made sense.
Because that engineer
was able to get
10x faster by trial and
error for this piece of code.
It's a non-trivial piece of
coding here to go do that.
So the student, Jonathan, who's
now a professor at Berkeley,
he basically, in one day,
in 60 lines of Halide,
he was able to beat 2x of
Adobe code in some sense.
And then Adobe, in
those days, didn't
generate any code for GPUs.
Because they decided GPUs
are changed too fast.
And they can't keep up updating
for GPUs in every generation.
Then they-- because of
that, they were not--
the Adobe applications
were not using GPUs.
So if you ran Photoshop,
it's not going to use a GPU.
Even if you mention
it has a GPU.
So Jonathan still had
some time left in the day.
So he said, OK, let me
try to write on GPUs.
So he just-- basically
the same code, he
changed GPUs and got a 9x
faster than the fastest Adobe
had ever had for
this piece of code.
So how did he do it?
Again, the key principle
here is decoupling algorithm
from schedule.
So algorithm, again,
is what is computed.
And the algorithm
defined the pipeline
of very simple pure
functions operating in there.
And execution order,
parallelism, all those things
is left for the schedule.
The pipeline of
Halide just looks
like this for the blur filter.
It says, OK, get the
image in x dimension.
And do it a blur
in the y dimension.
That's all.
And the image size is--
because it's operating
on the entire image,
you don't have loops in here.
That's all you
have to say there.
Then you have to come
up with a schedule.
Again, the same way when
and where it's computed,
to be simple, that you need
to be able to tell that.
And it has be powerful.
You need to be able to get
the hand-optimized performance
or better by doing this.
Something looks a
little bit familiar.
Because it's all these
things, a lot of work
you do performance kind
of fit into this genre.
You need to do a trade off
between locality, parallelism,
and redundant work.
That's what you
look for in here.
So let's look at the three
things you need to do.
First, you need to
get parallelism.
Parallelism is you need to
keep the multi-cores and vector
units happy and
probably the GPU busy.
But if you have too
much parallelism,
it's not going to help you.
I mean, nobody is going to
take advantage [INAUDIBLE]
parallelism.
So let's look at a
piece of code in here.
So assume I am going
to say, I'm going
to run all these things
parallel and all these things
parallel afterwards.
If you have three cores--
great, I got a lot
more parallelism.
I got six times parallelism.
Hurrah, nobody's
going to use that.
It's not that useful to get
six times parallelism in here.
On the other hand, if you
run like this, one at a time,
you have parallelism of one.
That's not that good.
Because you're going
to not use the machine.
So what you really want
is something basically--
OK, wait till it's
done-- that actually
do parallelisms
of three might be
the best way of
running that machine
to get best performance.
You don't want too much.
You don't want too little.
You want to get the
exact right thing.
The next interesting thing
you need to get is locality.
Normally, when you do image
processing, what you do
is you change everything
in the image in one filter.
Then the next filter has to
go in and change everything
in the image.
So what happens
if one filter ran
through the entire
image and the next
come and start running
through the entire image?
What happens, basically?
Is that good?
I give the entire
image, say you,
do my first color correction.
And I will do some kind
of aberration correction
afterwards.
So what happens if you
do something like that?
Entire image,
process one filter,
then the next filter takes the
image and process the entire
[INAUDIBLE] or whatever
multi-megapixel image--
oh, you-- you're
on a [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, back there.
AUDIENCE: You end up
kicking [INAUDIBLE]..
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE:
[INAUDIBLE] cache.
Because if the image is large,
it doesn't fit in the cache.
It's not that great to do this.
You won't get things
in the cache in here.
So assume I go like this,
processing the entire first row
before you go to the second row.
So what happens now here is we
need to start touch this one--
I need to read these two values.
And those two
are-- the last time
I read them was way
before I started.
So I [INAUDIBLE] them.
I went through all the image.
And I come back to that.
And this distance-- by
the time I reach here,
I might-- these two might
be out of the cache.
And when I go back there,
oops, it's not in the cache.
I have a problem in that.
So the other way, a
right way to do that
might be trying it this way.
If I run it like
this, basically, what
happens is as you run--
when I touch this,
I won't have--
I want to get these
three to run this thing.
Last time I read this
one was just before,
in the previous iteration.
So to get to that--
I just touched it.
So the next guy uses it, the
next guy, and after, after.
I go to my window.
I've never touched that again.
I have a really good
locality in here.
So I want to
operate it that way.
I won't get good
locality in here.
So redundant work is a
very interesting thing.
Sometimes, if you want to get
both locality and parallelism,
you might have to
do some extra work,
a little bit of extra work.
So assume in this one I had to
process these elements parallel
if I want to run these three.
Because these three needs all
these four elements in there.
These three need these four.
If I want to run these
two parallel in two
different cores, it
might be better if both
calculates these two values.
Because I don't have to
synchronize and stuff.
I can say, the left guy,
calculate four values.
And then I can do the three.
The right guy, calculate
the four values.
And then I can do the three.
I can do that parallelly.
But now the middle two guys,
these two get calculated twice.
Because both needs it.
And so what that means is--
oops, you can keep that.
So sometimes, to
do everything, I
might have to do
some redundant work.
So the way to look at
that is I can put this
into this scheduling framework.
I can map my
computation bandwidth.
That means coarse interleaving
with low locality.
That means I finish
everything before I go back
in here between two things.
If I run two things,
I finish this one
before I go to the next one.
Fine interleaving means I
process one element one,
duh duh duh duh, go back
and back and forth in here.
That's my two options here.
Other side is
storage granularity.
What that means is--
storage granularity very low
means I calculate something,
I don't remember.
Next time I want it, I
recalculate it again.
Very high storage granularity
means once I calculate it,
I will remember it forever.
Anytime you need that value,
I have it back for you.
So that means I have to
get it to you from anywhere
I calculated.
Storage granularity low means
my process, I calculate, I use,
I throw it out.
If anybody else want it,
they'll recalculate again.
So now you can have many
different computations
in different places
of this space in here.
So if you want to
compute something here,
this is the scheduling language.
That means I run this
one, and I run this one.
I have no redundant
computation, very
coarse grained interleaving.
That means I run the
entire thing, and then
the next entire thing.
You can go very fine
[INAUDIBLE] in here.
I'll calculate this one.
And I'll calculate these three
again, these three again.
So everything is
calculated multiple times.
When you need it, I recalculate
every time I need something.
I don't store anything in here.
So it's good.
I have a lot of locality.
But I'm doing a lot
of recomputation.
And then here,
you have something
like a sliding window.
Basically, you are not
recalculating anything.
But you are sliding in there.
You have a little
bit less parallelism.
And then you could capture
this entire spectrum
in between in here.
And you can get different
levels of fusion of these tiles.
And you can calculate--
so I don't recalculate
everything.
I recalculate a
few things in here.
These two get recalculated.
And then you can--
I'll go through this
fast [INAUDIBLE]..
You can use all
these operations.
So here is the
interesting thing.
So here is I am showing
you different schedules
at different points in here.
So I'm going to run this game.
This is on time.
So what it says
is this is doing--
you're going through
the first input,
[INAUDIBLE] the middle one,
[INAUDIBLE] the output in here.
So this has all locality,
lot of redundant work,
good patterns of locality.
All patterns have
not good locality.
In here is some kind
of intermediate thing.
So what it shows is
these are no good.
A good balance between
locality, parallelism,
and some redundant work
seem to do really well.
This guy finished the fastest.
So what you do is you
write different schedules
for these things.
And you keep running.
And we figured out
what schedule works.
So this is kind of
trial and error part
you have to do in here.
So if you look at
what's going on
in here, what you see here is--
there's some example-- is
bilateral filter computation
here.
What it says is the original
is about 122 lines of C++ code.
And you found something with
a good parallelism in here.
But we could write it in
32 lines of Halide in here.
And we were able to get
about 6x faster than CPU.
But the best algorithm
was somebody hand
wrote for the paper on GPUs.
And what it did it was it
gave up some parallelism
for much better locality.
And if you give up some
parallelism, much better
locality, because we
can optimize in that,
we got faster than their
handwritten algorithm.
So we can change something.
Here's, again,
another algorithm that
is doing segmenting in here.
And it was written in MATLAB.
And MATLAB is a lot less
lines of code, of course.
But in Halide, it's a
little bit more line,
because you're not just
calling library functions.
And Halide was 70 times faster.
And if you run into GPU verses
MATLAB, it's about 100--
1,000 times faster.
It's not because you're
running bad MATLAB loops.
In fact, what MATLAB did was it
called very well hand-optimized
libraries.
But the problem with calling
libraries, there's no locality.
I called a really fast
library for first routine.
It runs really fast.
And then you call
the next routine
that has to [INAUDIBLE]
the entire image again.
And now my image is
completely off the cache.
So what happens is between
these very fast libraries,
you're bringing the
image from cache.
And when you have
something like a library,
you can't fuse library
functions together.
In Halide, we can
confuse them together
and say, oh, I take
this line of the image,
and I will do everything
on that before I
move to the next thing.
So I can do much faster.
My feeling is each
function probably,
in MATLAB was faster, because
they have a handwritten really
fast thing.
But the copying of data from--
the moving from cache,
the cache effects,
was really slowing it down.
So here's the thing
that we showed before.
This is a very
complicated algorithm.
It's what we call a
pyramidal algorithm.
So what it does is you
take a [INAUDIBLE] in here.
And you divide it into a
bunch of blocks in here
in each level of pyramid.
And you do some computation,
do some look up, and do some
up sampling in here.
You do some addition
computation and compute that.
And then you create more and
more smaller and smaller images
in here.
You do-- you basically
[INAUDIBLE] image pyramid
in here.
And so to do this right,
it's not that simple.
What that means, in
each of these level,
there are different
balances you want to be.
If you have a lot of
data, parallelism is not
that important at that point.
Because you have
parallelism anyways.
You probably had to focus
a lot more on locality.
But when you get to
the smaller amount,
I think parallelism matters.
So you have to come up with
very interesting balances
between those.
So many, many things
to tune at every level.
There's not three things.
There's hundreds of
different levels.
So the nice thing
about Halide is
you can play with
all these things.
You can play with all
these different concepts
and figure out which
actually gives the fastest
performance in that.
So a little bit of, I
would say, bragging rights
in here for Halide, Halide
left MIT about, I think,
six years ago.
And right now, it's
everywhere in Google.
So it's on Android phones.
It started to Google Glass.
It doesn't exist
anymore, but in that--
and in fact, any--
all the images, all the videos
uploaded to YouTube right now,
they do front end processing.
And that processing pipeline
is written in Halide.
And they switched to Halide
because Halide code was about,
I think 4-5% faster than
the previous version.
And 4-5% faster for Google
was multi-million dollars
saved for them, because
there's so many videos
getting downloaded from that.
So recently, there's a
Photoshop announcement
that's saying they have an
IOS version of Photoshop
from Adobe.
They just announced it.
I don't think it's even out yet.
And the entire
Photoshop filters are
written in this new
version using Halide.
Qualcomm released this processor
called Snapdragon image
processor.
So they built that processor to
do image processing in there.
And the programming language
to program that processor
is basically Halide.
So you write the code in Halide.
So that is the kind
of-- the assembly level
that makes it available
for this in here.
And also, Intel is using that.
So there's lot of use of this
system at this point, which
is really fun to see academic
project getting to a point it's
very heavily used.
And part of that is
because it's very useful.
Because people realize
they need to optimize
these code, because cameras
and stuff, performance matter.
And it needs to look-- having
some poor engineer spending
months in the corner, just
trying out those things,
you can try the same things,
and lot more by do it faster.
OK so let me ask you a question.
So now between Halide and
GraphIt, what did you find?
A bunch of similarities--
I want to figure out are there
any interesting similarities
you guys found between
these two projects?
AUDIENCE: They both allow you to
try optimizations really fast.
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE:
So part of that
is also a lot of times
compilers are kind of black box.
We know everything,
just feed us,
we'll give you the
really fast code.
And the problem is,
they're never the fastest.
So if you really care about
performance, you get 90%.
Then you get really
frustrated-- now what do I do?
But this was, OK,
I'm not going to--
you are better at what to do.
But I'll make you life simpler.
So we still want the
performance engineer.
It's not the person who just
don't understand performance
feed, you get fast code.
We need a performance--
but we want
to make performance
engineers life easier.
So both of them, said, OK,
we need performance engineer.
We can't automate it.
We don't know how to
automate all these things.
There's too much complexity.
But we will let you, performance
engineer, explain what to do.
But we'll make your
life very simple.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Something
that was cool
was both of these
languages can do
algorithmic level
optimizations [INAUDIBLE],,
which is pretty different
from what compilers like GCC
are explained [INAUDIBLE].
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE:
Yeah, because--
I wouldn't say alg--
you can do a lot of domain
specific optimization.
So algorithmic optimization
is one level higher.
You can say, ah ha, I
have a better algorithm.
So, OK, I don't want to
do a quick search here.
I can do insertion sort.
Because quick
sorting and insertion
sort might be faster for
a certain class in there.
So that is level
change we don't do.
Or, worse yet, I can say--
this happens in a lot of things
in machine learning-- yeah,
if I just drop a
number here, I'm OK.
I don't have to get the
compute exactly right.
Oh yeah, if I--
I don't have to
calculate everything.
If I calculate for 10
people, it's good enough.
So that kind of
changes, you can't do.
Because that's very contextual.
Like, for example,
a lot of time,
if you are doing things
like machine learning,
there's no right answer.
You need to have a good answer.
So sometimes good means you
can not do certain things.
And you need to find what things
you shouldn't-- you cannot do,
that you get a huge benefit,
but you don't lose that much.
That level you can't do that.
That's the next level of
[INAUDIBLE] is saying, OK,
how do you do that?
How do you-- when
somebody say, OK, look,
I can train it for 10
iterations versus 100--
ah, 10 is good enough.
I can't-- if your code is
written to train for 100
iterations, I can't tell you,
oh yeah, 10 is good enough.
That is a decision that has to
be a lot higher level than what
I can make.
So that's a-- that-- there's
an interesting level that
can still exist on top of that,
which we can't automate that
easily.
But we might be
able to make, still,
a language, like a schedule
language, give you that option.
That's a cool
option to give, say
try some of these things that
actually change the algorithm.
But within the algorithm,
that means I'll still
give you the same answer.
I will try different things.
Any other things?
Any other things you guys
thought that was interesting?
How about from somewhere here?
What are the interesting
things you found?
Back there.
AUDIENCE: They both involve
a lot of trial and error.
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE:
Yes, both involve
a lot of trial and error.
I mean, this is the
modern computer systems.
Everything is
extremely complicated.
There's no right
way of doing things
when you look at this
pretty large piece of code.
And there might be
a lot of-- there
are caches, parallelism,
locality, a lot of things
that can go right.
And so you might have
to try out many things.
So if you know the answer,
if you come up with the,
I know exactly, every time,
I have the right answer,
that's amazing.
But even the best
performance person
might not be able to look at a
piece of code and say, ah ha,
I know your solution.
You do a lot of trial and error.
This kind of supports that.
And you probably have
figured that one out
for most of your projects.
It's not like you went and
say, ah, I know what to do.
You probably did many
different trials.
And I know from
this, lot of things,
you actually either have no
impact or slow down the code.
And you say, oh,
that didn't work.
And all if-- [INAUDIBLE]
you leave in your codes
shows all the crazy
things you've tried,
and nothing happened.
So that's an interesting thing.
What else?
Anything else, a
little bit differently
that you see on this one?
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering,
are there other similar domains
that don't have something
like this [INAUDIBLE]??
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE: So
interesting question--
are there any other domains that
don't have something like this?
People are working
on similar things
to machine learning these days.
That seems to be their
domain, and tensor flow,
and all those people
are trying to do--
to build systems like
similar-- like frameworks
that you can get that.
I mean, that's a very--
I think-- the way
I have operated
is I go talk to people.
And sometimes you find
this poor graduate student,
or postdoc who want to do
some research but spending all
of their time basically
optimizing their piece of code,
because they can't
get their performance.
And then that might
be a good domain.
You find these
people in physics.
people in biology.
And I am actually talking to--
because, for
example, in biology,
a lot of this gene
sequencing stuff is--
there are very similar
things you have to do.
But they seem to be
spending all this time
writing the code, and then--
mired in code complexity.
OK, can you do
something in that?
I mean, the key thing is this
is a good way to-- a nice thing
about MIT is there are good--
a lot of very smart people
in many different domains trying
to push the state of the art.
And who's spending all this time
cursing in front of a computer
program to get to a
point they want to do,
because-- not because they
don't know the algorithm,
because the amount of data
they have to deal with--
astronomy, I mean they get
these multiple telescopes,
that deluge of data.
And most of the time, they
know what they have to do.
They just have to--
can't write the program
to do it fast enough.
So there might be domains like
that, if you look at that.
And there might be domains
from application and domains
from patterns.
Like sparse matrices
or graphs are
patterns, which-- or not
only on a single application.
I mean, it works
in multiple places.
There might be other patterns.
Say, this is-- if you
want to do research,
this might be interesting
piece of doing research.
And I have spent my life finding
different domains and a bunch
of people that spend their
lifetime just hand hacking
things and telling them,
OK, let me see if we
can do some nice abstraction.
Anything that you guys
found that's interesting?
So to both of them,
what are-- what's
the space that they operated
on to optimize programs?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE:
Done for me, no.
What I'm saying is,
what are the things
that you're trying to optimize?
There's a nice space of
three different things--
parallelism, locality,
and redundant work.
My feeling is, as you go as a
performance engineer, that's
going to be your life.
If I add additional
things, there
might be algorithmic things that
you completely get rid of well.
But most of the time, we are--
all of you will be
[INAUDIBLE] performance
will be working on some kind
of multi-core vector GPU type
units.
You have to get parallelism.
So getting parallelism
is important.
But then, if you don't have
locality, it doesn't matter.
Because most of the time
you're waiting to get data
from all the way from memory.
So you had to get good locality.
And then more-- a
lot of times you
can do that really well if
you do some extra computation.
But if you do too much extra
things, that's going to,
oh well, that's not
going to help you.
So it's all about
playing the distribution.
You've got a final project.
That's exactly what
you're going to do.
You might say, ah, if I
can do some extra work,
OK, I can do this faster.
But oops, no, this extra
pre-compute pass, or whatever,
it's not--
I can't amortize the cost.
So there's these three things
that you're trading over that.
So that's one interesting thing.
Another thing is we made it
available for the programmers
to do this scheduling language.
But can you make it--
can you think of
a way to make it
a little bit easier
for programmers
than doing a
scheduling language?
What can I do?
What's the nice thing
about scheduling languages?
It's very simple.
It has a very simple pattern.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE: Yeah, I
mean, that's-- the number
of options--
it's not like you can
write any program.
There are certain things
you can do in the schedule.
So if you know that
space, you can sort of
use doing that smartly.
What else can we do with it?
AUDIENCE: Test them all.
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE:
Test them all.
That's one approach there.
AUDIENCE: Use autotuning,
trying to find [INAUDIBLE]..
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE:
We can do autotuning.
So that switched into the
autotuning part of this talk.
So performance engineering
basically, most of the time,
is finding right
these crazy things.
Like you start looking
at, I think, probably
as Charles talked, what
this voodoo parameters,
like, OK, what's the
right block size?
And it has a big
impact, finding that.
A newer memory
allocation project,
you had to find
the right strategy,
right memory allocation.
You searched through a
bunch of these things.
You and GCC compiler,
there are, I
think, about 400
different flags for GCC.
And you can actually get
factor of four performance
by having a [INAUDIBLE]
200 flags into GCC.
It's crazy.
And that 200 flags is not
the same for every program.
And, of course, some programs
will crash in some places.
Most of the time, it'll
slow down or speed up.
So you can just give all the
flags of GCC and autotune that.
And you can get factor of two
to four performance in there.
It's just crazy.
And then, because it do weird
things in there, and then 01,
02, 03 will only
do certain amount.
So 03 doesn't-- it's
not always right.
You can try all these things.
So you can tune that.
And scheduling Halide,
scheduling GraphIt,
all these things
can be autotuned.
So before autotuning, when
you have a large search space,
what do we normally do?
The thing that when we think
we are smart, what we do
is we build models.
We have model for a cache.
And say, can we
understand the cache?
We have all these
nice models in here.
And using the model,
I can predict, ah ha,
this is the right block size.
So what's the problem when
you try to do a model?
AUDIENCE: Sometime it
doesn't work [INAUDIBLE]..
SAMAN AMARASIGNHE:
Exactly, because most
of the time, when you try to do
a model, you have to abstract.
And most of the time,
you-- what you abstract out
might be the most important
part of the darn thing
that we didn't consider.
So we built a model for cache.
But oops, I could--
didn't figure out pages.
Well, the pages made
a big difference.
So there might be
things in real life
that matters that didn't
fit into your model,
or you didn't know it needed
to be fit into a model.
If you try to put
everything, that's
too complicated of a model.
So you abstract something out.
You can say, I have optimal
result for this model.
But that optimal
result might be way off
than the simple
result you can get.
Because the thing that
you didn't put into
the model are the
important ones.
So model doesn't work.
The next thing is what you
do, heuristic-based thing.
This is where these old
people come and say,
I know how to do this.
In order to do this, you need
to do this thing, this thing,
this thing.
You can come up with some
kind of the old grandmother's
solution type thing.
There are certain things
that will always work.
And you hardcode them.
So you can say if the matrix
dimension is more than 1,000,
always go to block, or some
kind of rules like that.
These rules work
most of the time.
But obviously, there are certain
cases that rules doesn't work.
Worse, that rules might be
set for a certain machine,
certain architecture,
all those things.
I'll give you the story.
So GCC has this fast
table sort routine.
So fast table sort
routine says sort
using a parallel quick sort.
And when the number exceeds
16, switch to in session sort.
It's hardcoded in GCC.
It's like, wow, some
amazing person figured
out 16, this amazing
number, has to switch
from parallel quick
sort to insertion sort.
So we are trying to
figure out, what's
the profoundness of this number?
The profoundness of this
number is somewhere around 1995
when this code was released.
In those machines, that
was the right number.
That 16 was a really good number
to switch from parallelism
to doing that, because the
cache size, stuff like that.
But that 16 survived
from 1995 [INAUDIBLE]
even two dates there.
Today that number
should be like 500.
But it's in there,
because somebody
thought 16 is the right,
it's hardcoded in there.
It didn't change.
So there are a lot of things
in compilers code like that,
that they draw, that
some programmer said,
I know what works here.
This fits in there.
You put it in there.
But there's no rhyme or reason.
Because at that time,
they had a reason.
But it doesn't scale.
So a lot of these heuristics
get out of focus very fast.
And there's no
theory behind this
to say, now, how do you update?
You had to ask people,
why did you put that?
And then it's, oh yeah,
because my machine
has a 32 kilobytes of cache.
It's like, oh, OK, that's
a different machine
what we have today.
So that's the problem in here.
And then other thing is you
can do exhaustive search.
You can say, OK, I'll
try every possible thing.
The problem here is
sometimes my search base
is 10 to the power 10.
You don't have enough
seconds in your lifetime
to do that search.
So it would be too complicated.
And that's where the
autotuner comes in.
So-- oh, OK, actually I have
a little bit more slides here.
So model based
solution is you come up
with this comprehensive
model, like a cache model,
or something like that.
And you do that.
And you can exactly show what's
right for the optimal solution
in here.
But the problem is
hard to build models,
cannot model everything, and
most of the time modeling is
the most important thing.
Heuristic-based
things are the rule
of the thumb kind of solution
that you come up and say,
it's hardcoded in there.
And it's very simple and easy.
It works most of the
time, if you get it right.
But the problem
is too simplistic.
It doesn't scale.
It doesn't stand the test of
time, most of the time in here.
An exhaustive search is great.
But the problem is
just way too much
possibility of searching in
here, too big of search base.
You can't do that.
So this is where you want
to prune the search base.
And the pruning, the
best way to do that
is basically use autotuning.
So what autotuning you can do
is you can define the space
of acceptable values nicely,
choose a value at random--
that's what the system
will do, try it out there--
and evaluate the performance
of that value end to end.
Because end to end matters.
Because if you try to
predict, most of the time,
it might not work.
And if satisfies the performance
that you need, you're done.
Otherwise, choose a new
value and iterate over there,
go to three in there.
So this is the kind of thing.
And what you have
to do is you need
to have a system to figure out
how to do this fast, basically
what space to basically do that,
when to basically think you're
done, how to go through the
iterating loops through that.
So this is the kind of--
with cartoonish way, what
happens is you give
a value candidate,
you compile the program, you
run it with bunch of data,
you are running
through the bunch,
otherwise you are all fitting.
You can't run it with one.
And you get the results.
And you get something
like average.
And if you go through
this loop in here.
And what OpenTuner
has done is come up
with the ensemble of techniques.
So the idea there is when you're
searching through a space,
you might be at the bottom
of a hill of the space.
So what that means is there
are certain value, if you keep
improving in value, that
you are getting good
better, and better, and better.
And at that time, something
like a hill climber--
hill climber, or somebody like
an [INAUDIBLE] hill climber
can actually give you
the best performance.
You're going very fast in there.
But meet you at the top of the
hill for that pyramid, oops,
there's no place to go.
So that if you
tried to hill climb,
it's not going to be helpful.
So at that time, what
do you want to do
is do something like a
random search in here.
So what this system do,
OpenTuner, you do it,
it will basically test
this request in there.
And if something
is doing very well,
it will give it more time.
If not, what it will do
is it will say, OK, look,
this is-- this technique
is not working.
Let's try something else.
It'll basically allocate
the time in here.
So it do this search much faster
than otherwise you can do.
So I want to finish this
by showing what you need
for autotuning for GraphIt.
So we have algorithm,
and you have a schedule.
It's a pain to
write this schedule.
In fact, there's a
good [? interesting ?]
thing in-- when
you do Halide, we
decided, OK, it should be
similar to write the algorithm
for Halide and the schedule.
Google very fast realized
many people won't use Halide.
And they-- at about two
years, they had about hundreds
of programmers who can
write the algorithm.
But they only had
five people who could
write the really good schedule.
To write a really
good schedule, you
need to understand a little
bit of the algorithm.
You need to understand a
little bit of the architecture,
a little bit of everything.
And that's much harder
for people to learn.
So getting the schedule
right is not that easy.
And same thing in
here, because you
need to understand a lot
unless you do kind of random--
you've got certain arbitrary,
but to do it right,
you need to know
a little bit more.
So what we can do
is we can basically
give some idea about
the graphs and some idea
about the algorithm in there.
We can autotune
these things in there
and then generate the schedule.
And so what we found was to
generate this schedule, if you
do exhaustive search,
it runs for days.
But if you're using
autotuner, OpenTuner,
you can find a really
good schedule for--
in less than two hours.
And, in fact, a few
cases we found schedules
that run better
than what we thought
was the best possible schedule.
Because it was able to--
because it was able to search
much better than our intuition
would say in here.
And when-- and even if
our intuition know it,
it has more time to try
many different combinations
and trying something in--
come something better in here.
So that's all I have today.